[00:31:14] Let's talk about lying.
I'm against lying.
And I know that that's a quaint statement
to make at this point.
But I want to hear the truth from our politicians,
even if it's not good.
But not all lying is created equal lying about
I reduce the deficit when in reality you reduce
the rate at which the deficit was growing.
Okay.
I mean, listen, these are lies.
They're provable lies, but it's very different
than the pandemic is under control.
It'll go away soon.
No one will die.
We will have few cases.
Donald Trump cannot and will not stop lying
about coronavirus.
And this included and it continued when he
announced the National Emergency for coronavirus
on Friday.
A national emergency for something he said
two weeks ago was nothing and would be going
away.
No, he announced it at a White House press
conference.
On Friday, and one of the things Donald Trump
announced was that Google is making a national
corona virus testing Web site where you can
type in your symptoms, follow a flow chart
process to be told do you need a test and
then be directed to the closest testing location
to go and get tested for covered 19.
Let's look take a look at what Donald Trump
said and then we'll look at what the truth
is.
[00:32:20][66.9]
[00:32:21] I want to thank Google.
Google is helping to develop a Web site.
It's going to be very quickly done.
Unlike websites of the best to determine whether
a test is warranted and to facilitate testing
that a nearby convenient location.
[00:32:38][16.7]
[00:32:39] Notice that Trump even interrupted
his lie there to say that other Web sites
weren't developed quickly.
He was referring to healthcare.gov, the Obamacare
Web site.
Again, just obsessed with Barack Obama, even
as we're in a national emergency now, the
real problem is Google had no idea what Trump
was talking about.
They had no idea Trump was going to announce
this.
Trump even said Google has seventeen hundred
engineers devoted to this project.
It was all a lie.
First of all, Google's doing nothing.
[00:33:07][28.5]
[00:33:08] Alphabet, which owns Google, has
a unit called Verily Verily, is working on
a tree Aage tool for a Corona virus testing
meant to be for health care workers in the
Bay Area who may be exposed in the process
of working to treat Corona virus.
Google immediately started getting a flood
of inquiries and questions.
When Trump announced this, they had to put
out a statement that included clarifying,
quote, statement from Verilli.
We are developing a tool to help Treloggen
individuals for Cauvin.
Testing barely is in the early stages of development,
planning to roll testing out in the Bay Area
with the hope of expanding more broadly over
time.
Trump can't stop lying.
Remember that in the Oval Office address last
week, he said We're shutting down all travel
from Europe.
Turns out U.S. citizens and U.S. residents
can go back and forth.
Wasn't true.
Trump said the Europe shut down includes cargo
and trade.
It didn't, but it still rocked the markets.
Trump said insurance companies were waiving
co-pays on corona virus treatment.
Turns out it was only co-pays on Corona virus
testing.
The man cannot stop lying.
It is life or death for many people.
It appears that Donald Trump has put not only
Mike Pence in a position of power in this
entire fiasco, but also Jared Kushner, who
knows absolutely nothing about infectious
disease or pandemics or public health or outbreaks.
He just knows nothing about it.
We're dealing with bad people who are also
incompetent and are in way over their heads.
How would you expect garbage in, garbage out?
How would we expect to get anything but garbage
coming out when everything that is being put
in is garbage by people who don't know what
they're doing?
[00:34:55][107.1]
[00:34:56] Are in over their heads and seem
to care more about optics and elections than
actually preventing death.
[00:35:01][4.8]
[00:35:02] That's the bottom line.
[00:35:03][1.9]
[225.9]